Coffee on the Tuesday and black.
Yay.
So today I want to talk about the
greatest writer that ever lived.
Now maybe you know,
or maybe you don't know,
but Roland emerick's new movie,
anonymous tickets is this Friday.
We'll know William Shakespeare,
the most famous author of all time,
right,
heard of 37 plays,
154 sonnets.
Several epic poem and why we are here
today.
But what if I told you Shakespeare never
wrote a single word.
Movies meant to explore the theory that
William Shakespeare,
the average man from Stratford,
did not actually write any poems or
playing.
Now,
conspiracy theories like this aren't
new,
but it may be important to note that not
a single person doubted shakespeare
until about 150 years after his death.
In 17,
69,
Herbert Lawrence publishes a book called
the life and adventures of common sense
suggests that the culprit might be in
fact Francis Bacon.
Shakespeare depicted as a degenerate and
a thief steals from the character called
wisdom,
who is the father of common sense.
And wisdom is meant to be amongst my
father's baggage.
She presently has designed upon a
commonplace book in which was contained
and infinite variety of modes and forms
to express all the different sentiments
of the human mind,
but this allegation is forgotten in its
time and isn't revived until Delia bake
in know relationships with the proper
treatment and her 582 page book,
the philosophy of the plays of
Shakespeare unfold in it.
She suggests that Bacon was directing a
group of intellectuals who actually
wrote all the place.
Oh,
clever bacon.
The Bacon theory falls completely into
madness.
When in 18,
88,
Ignatius Donnelly starts claiming that
he's found codes inside the texts.
That's not all.
By the way,
Bacon,
according to Donald,
is also Christopher Marlowe and
maintained to check out these two final
lines from the epilogue of the tempest
as you from crimes with pardon be
lecture,
indulgence set me free.
According to the audience.
These lines are actually an Anagram for
tempest of Francis Bacon.
Lord Vellum,
do you narrow divulge me words?
It is a shame that the literary appears
twice in the first lines in three times
the second lines,
but no problem say that they come here,
just pop it apostrophe here and Bob's
your uncle.
Apostrophes are so helpful like that,
but the man who was more recently
replaced back in as the elite contender,
the protagonist,
the Roland emerick's film anonymous
Edward de Vere,
the 17th earl a box for this theory was
advanced in two large books by Charlton
alcorn and his wife.
This star of England and the mysterious
William Shakespeare of the central
arguments,
what the man from strapper couldn't
possibly have had the brain or the
experience to write all those plays.
Only the Lord could have written them to
do their,
had the perfect social background,
living for years and Queen Elizabeth
Court and three did not want his name to
be known because a writing plays was
considered a vulgar pursuit for royalty
and be the place show so much slimy,
corrupt,
loyal behavior that it would have just
totally blown up his spot.
And let's not leave out the secret codes
single.
Look at this line from act one.
Scene five of the time is that of joint.
Oh,
curse.
It's right.
They never.
I was born to set it right.
What?
Oh,
oh,
no,
no.
Come on
about the poem by Ben Johnson and titled
to the Memory of my beloved William
Shakespeare and that Johnson called
Shakespeare the swan of Avon.
Oops.
Sticking to bear.
Have property on the Avon River.
Nevermind that Shakespeare was born in,
died in Stratford on bond.
This Johnson poem was actually the
preface to the first folio,
which is the first time that all of
Shakespeare's plays were collected in
one place in 16,
23.
The folio was prepared by John
Hemorrhages and Henrico doctors who had
worked with Shakespeare for 20 years and
gave him repeated credit of authorship
and nevermind.
Also the Edward de Vere died in 16.
Oh,
four.
And a play like the tempest for example,
is clearly dated 2:16,
11.
You know the [inaudible] have an answer
for that.
They have an answer for everything,
but each arm reaches further and further
out of its socket to find connections
that just don't exist.
And round and round we go.
Even Herman Melville and his final book,
Billy Budd names the captain of the
ship,
Indomitable Edward,
there,
Melville later said on that subject,
the names of all fine authors are
fictitious ones simply standing as they
do for the mystical,
ever alluding spirit of all beauty which
ubiquitously possesses men of genius,
but I think we shouldn't let this make
us complacent when it comes to the
smearing of Shakespeare's name.
The people who don't have as much
craving for conspiracy as Roland
Emmerich won't suddenly be turned by his
movie,
but the world is full of idiots.
It's full of people sitting on their
couches and watching TV and watching the
trailer flicker by and saying to the
other guy on the couch,
hey,
actually,
you know,
that's true.
He never did write those plays.
There's like evidence.
There needs to be some respect for human
genius,
especially when that genius comes from
simple beginnings because that is where
most genius comes from.
It comes from Lincoln Shyer or the
Bronx,
or it comes from Liverpool or Stratford.
It grows out of practice and it comes
from the stars and I don't mean from
aliens.
Oh,
in,
I mean that a genius can be any person
who looks at a night sky full of stars
and never gets over it for the rest of
his life.
He does not in the stars to hold our
destiny,
but in ourselves.